[Music]
joining me is an evolutionary biologist
formerly of Evergreen State University
who is now a professional professor in
exile Heather hi and welcome to the
Reuben report thank you for having us
dance professor in exile I believe that
is in your Twitter bio it is I believe
it is in your husband Brett Weinstein's
Twitter bio yeah we generated just
together is that gonna be the title of
the co-authored book when the dust
settles on all of this stuff oh I don't
know I think both of us are both eager
to leave the Evergreen story behind but
still heartbroken that an institution
that we loved and still believe in the
educational model that it offered and
still believed in the students who got
great education was there for many
decades we we would love to see it
resurrected but it doesn't look like
it's gonna happen yeah all right so this
is it's a little crazy to me that this
is the first time that we've met because
obviously our circles have been sort of
closing in on each other for for quite
some time so when when the whole
Evergreen thing happened and I only want
to spend a little bit of time at the top
talking about and then I want to do all
sorts of evolutionary biology stuff and
the other the other things that you're
really passionate about the story
obviously was more focused on Brett and
then he was sort of thrust into the
media and all that but this was a direct
attack on you as well and as you said
the institution that you loved and all
that can you just give me any sort of
recap or just pieces of it that maybe we
don't know that well or just her
perspective on what was happening there
well as briefly as I can leaving out
many many relevant pieces we got a new
president and the new president very
quickly got rid of a Provost who was
going to get in his way and spoke
publicly about his desire to turn
evergreen into the social justice
college that was actually on the record
early in George bridges tenure at the
point that the protests broke out a year
ago now-ish he had been president for
about two years and a year before that
had broken out in equity
a desire to bring equity and inclusion
to the forefront which is which is
codewords it's dog whistles for the
people on the far left who are actually
interested in a reversal of power not an
end to oppression but an actual reversal
of historical oppression did you guys
recognize those things as dog whistles
at the time because as Brett said at the
time he considers himself or at least at
that time did consider himself deeply
progressive you just said to me right
before we started you still consider
yourself progressive yeah so did you
realize those buzz words and and what
they actually meant at the time
absolutely
I mean Brett actually I was on
sabbatical that you're most of the year
before this broke out is murder and why
I was disappeared from the story I said
as I went onto sabbatical Brett I will
continue to read everything you want to
send out to these lists but I am not
engaging I am doing my own work now so
about a year actually a year to the day
before the protests broke out the first
announcement of the new plan came came
live and then and there and for the next
year Brett was I was a little bit a
couple of other people who are a little
bit standing up and saying this doesn't
smell right this this feels like this is
actually about something that we're not
talking about and furthermore if we are
actually interested in improving the
fate of various demographic groups these
processes are not going to be the way to
accomplish them so we were saying that
Bret mostly was saying that a few others
of us were saying it and was there any
sort of understanding of that point of
view privately yes
privately yes people were scared and
when in fact when Brett used the phrase
culture of fear on campus what came back
at him was you have to prove that
there's a culture of fear or else
there's not one and you know show me the
people who aren't standing up or else I
will know that they they don't exist
which is you know it's baffling yeah
right it's it is obviously an improve an
unprovable statement to say there's a
culture of fear and I'm not going to out
the people who have come to me
they're scared as I actually am going to
honor their privacy but if if everyone
who had come to us privately and said
this is nuts and it's got to stop
had stood up it would have been a
totally different outcome well that's
the culture of fear summed up right
there right okay so without rehashing
the whole thing can you just tell me a
little bit about sort of how your life
has changed throughout this and sort of
you know look you and Bret you guys did
settle it wasn't for a ton of money at
least in my humble estimation but I
think you probably wanted to just put
some of this behind you but you guys are
professors and I saw you if you have
kids and family and all that stuff and
just sort of sum up kind of where you're
at at the moment yeah so I mean we had
we've been living in Olympia for 15
years the the college was an amazing
place to really do a deep dive in
community with students and so you know
Bret and I had done one and I had done
several long study abroad trips in
Panama and in Ecuador with pretty large
groups of undergraduates taking them
through the Amazon through Galapagos we
spent time in the field in Washington
State in the San Juans in Eastern
Washington took people places where not
only we were studying evolutionary
biology and animal behavior and field
techniques and statistics of the
philosophy of science but also coming to
know each other such that after you
after you break bread with people for
days and you play ultimate with them and
you sit around a campfire you come to
understand that when they disagree with
you it's not inherently coming from a
place of hatred or personal animosity
and so that trust that we were able to
create in our classrooms which both of
us love to doing allowed us to
effectively then rip the intellectual
rug out from under people when they made
claims that weren't falsifiable or
couldn't be it couldn't be justified
once you started to ask them what the
assumptions were they were underlying
their claims that was that was an
amazing gift and I don't know that
really almost any other educational
model out there allows for that because
it required the time to build community
with students which was which was
wonderful so yes we lost to tenure track
jobs along with our health insurance and
our retirement plans and all of that and
have two kids still in school so that's
alarming
but some of what we were doing in the
classroom we have begun to do on larger
stages and that is promising it seems
clear that the world is interested in
hearing how to understand systems from
an evolutionary perspective I knew that
was true from the 25 or 50 students that
I had doing the deep dive for every
quarter every year for years it's not
that surprising but it is heartening to
see that that is the response of many
many people out there in a weird way
does it almost feel right then that this
happened I mean I know it's kind of
sucky and again with the salaries and
tenure-track positions and all that but
that the message that you guys are
talking about seems so relevant right
now you guys are now doing more public
speaking gigs I'm dragging Brett on
stage with me to do stand-up and all
sorts of crazy things are presenting
themselves and then the sort of the rise
of this new alliance of whether you want
to call it intellectual dark web or
whatever you want to call it at this
point but there is this sort of
interesting crew of people with a lot of
different feelings on a lot of different
issues with all sorts of different
disciplines coming together and maybe if
you guys were still at university in a
traditional sense you wouldn't be able
to be dealt in the way that you are now
I think that's possible I think there is
both a way in which having gone through
the looking-glass having gone through
the direct you know to borrow a phrase
from the far left but the lived
experience of actually being at the
center of a mob at the center of riots
and then watching as the world the
mainstream media and others tried to do
a public relations spin on it and tell a
totally different story
to live that and to watch the
institution that you love to become
totally disloyal to you and to watch
many people whom you respected hide you
can't don't see that it's valuable and
the fact that we're sitting here talking
together and that many of us in you know
the intellectual dark web and in this in
this bigger group are are speaking and
saying actually the culture of fear that
is society-wide
is real and so I'll say the the first
time I met my students after
November 2016 election after Trump was
selected evergreen it's a very left
place Olympia is a very left place
pretty much everyone on campus had that
glazed eyes slack-jawed look that people
in most progressive enclaves will be
familiar with from that time from those
few days right
myself included even though I was no
Hillary fan but I didn't see that
outcome coming and I certainly didn't
vote for Trump I am we got to class and
my co faculty whom I admire greatly just
preceded with her lecture on horse
evolution and I'm looking around the
classroom going no one here cares about
horse so she ended a bit early and we
had lab a couple hours later and before
she let them go I said hold on if anyone
wants to stay this is no longer class
but if anyone wants to stay I would be
happy to lead a conversation about what
just happened yeah what just happened to
our country and about 40 of our 50
students stayed well skip their lunch
hour again we went right to anatomy lab
that afternoon from from this
conversation and what I said to them was
do not for a minute believe that racists
and sexist elected Trump think about how
many times you have had to censor
yourself on this campus when you had an
opinion that was even slightly different
from the accepted dogma and that
conversation not only brought life to
the room but afterwards I had several
students come up to me some of them in
tears telling me stories about one of
them had lost a job on campus for
speaking an opinion that was not
accepted one of them had an another
story of another friend who'd lost a job
others talked about their self
censorship and that and all of these
people again were for left not that it
should matter but these work even people
who were conservatives or who held
conservative views so that that is the
larger culture of fear that is hardly
restricted to Evergreen but is
society-wide that we are that we are
speaking about and that people are
responding to because in you know at
Google at Starbucks in cubicles in
campuses but far beyond campuses
the country and across the weird country
is at least this is a problem well the
irony to me is that I think that all
that I'm doing is talking about these
things often with people who have a much
better
pedigree than I do but by me talking
about it it's giving room for other
people to talk about that's all that
they want well you're also you oh you
are also providing ways into the
conversation I think so there are a lot
of people when confronted with you're
not allowed to think that say oh god I'm
not actually sure how to respond I
haven't I don't know I don't I don't
have the linguistic skills I don't have
the analytics behind me I don't know
what I'm supposed to say here and so
just listening to to you and to sam
Harris and the Jordan Peterson and to
Brett and to Eric and to me and to know
many many others I believe begins to
give people a sense of not only is this
doable these are good reasonable smart
people who are being respectful and what
they're saying but also it's not just
tools it's actually like freezes it's
you know this is what you can say these
are the things that sort of things that
you can say in response that are still
respectful and don't reject the humanity
of the person on the other side but do
reject the argument it's interesting it
almost shows that what you guys
obviously were doing so well at a
university level that's exactly what's
needed at a societal level now talking
about the language the language to get
these ideas across is so important I
wonder is there a evolutionary
explanation for a little bit of what has
happened here with the left like the way
they've sort of closed off ranks and
then purged everyone because it's just
as I sit here with you it's like the
idea that you and Brett wouldn't be
enough of whatever it is that they want
is so bananas and yet it is true so is
there some way that you can explain that
coming from the discipline you come from
well there's I think this is not going
to be a particularly deep point but it's
it's basic in-group out-group dynamics
and we will always we will not get rid
of of tribal thinking we will not get
rid of our sense of you know you and I
are aligned right that's that's a good
thing there's a way in which there's a
kind of tribalism there even though we
just met for the first time today you're
not and
and we definitely have political
differences and I'm sure which we can
talk about if we won't have right so we
end but but that isn't the main thing
like we're aligned and I you know I feel
walking in here like you've got my back
and you've got my back and I think
people especially raised without much
experience with the physical world and
raised often in situations where they're
being given a number of pharmaceuticals
early on that are disrupting development
arrive at what should be the cusp of
adulthood and aren't sure how to
navigate aren't sure how to navigate the
waters and so when told oh if you just
agree with everything if you just become
an ideologue and go in lockstep with us
you can be with us so you know identity
politics is appealing because it
provides an instant in-group if you will
only subjugate yourself yeah and you
know identity politics on this side
begets at Annie politics on this side of
course because anyone who shows up here
and is told no you don't have enough of
what the progressive stack tells us you
need either you can totally subjugate
yourself or go over there well of course
we're going to get a rise over here and
back and forth when people criticize us
whoever this is for not focusing on that
identity politics enough the the one
that the secondary one that you're
talking about here which is the identity
politics of the right which is either
which is based in actual racism or or
you know there's a white at no state or
ideas that are so the antithesis of the
American experiment it to me they're
they're ridiculous and have no real
real-world traction it's almost like
we've created this boogeyman because we
need it they've long since been just
like what no no almost no one thinks
that way anymore
sorry no well so what's your what's your
best argument against that well people
say well you're not focusing on that
enough because because everyone wants
everything to be equal all the time so
if you're focusing on the identity
politics the left which clearly many of
us see is I mean I truly see it I've
been saying this and I really believe
this I view it as the greatest
existential threat to Western democracy
that there is I believe that if there's
something that would cause us to be on
the streets like killing each other I
think it's that we're will have broken
off and all of the commonalities will
disappear but what what do you
is the best argument for what you're not
focusing on that one enough because I
see that a lot now right I think I think
two things one it's not as big a group
right the the white nationalists to the
extent that they exist only do our
better armed by-and-large than than the
far left but numerically they just don't
exist in the same numbers and they don't
have the kind of play they don't have
the kind of cultural reach that the far
left does and so that's the second well
I guess there's three points a secondary
point then is everyone can walk white
nationalists that is completely
acceptable and in fact demanded that you
do when those sorts of ideas come up in
conversation whereas the stuff on the
far left increasingly it is demanded
that you not using so there is that's a
key right there right so like we are
saying no actually we must we must
disagree with this just as much as we
should just as much as culturally we now
know it's a norm to disagree with what's
on the right we the far right it should
become a cultural norm to disagree with
frankly the cryptic racism and sexism
and you know and everything else that's
happening on the far left it is it comes
packaged as if it's anti-racist and
anti-sexist and all it's just it's
racist and sexist against the other
group it's it's a flipping of the the
tables of oppression so I would say the
third point is for me anyway as someone
who has been on the left my whole life
this has changed this experience is
going through the looking-glass in the
last year has not changed my values but
it has changed what I understand about
how people are using language to make
other people out to be things they're
not yeah so you know I no longer believe
in a massive alt right for instance
right right and you know the the boogie
men that are out there that you're not
supposed to do things like talk to Fox
News mm-hmm sorry
no actually we should all be exposing
ourselves to to the media across the
entire range and for me on the left it's
actually my job much more so than to go
after people who I have nothing in
common with
to go after the people who claim to have
values that are similar to mine but I
see that they are actually achieving
goals that are different yeah and that's
why I love this conversation and I don't
get tired of it because we're all in on
it
at different levels we all have
different realizations at different
times along the timeline and it's like
for me that's where I'm free for two
years I kept saying I'm of the left and
that's why I want to fix this I don't
think realistically anymore I can
honestly say that I think I have more in
common certainly with libertarians and I
find him I find an intellectual openness
with conservatives that I just don't
find any more on this other side and I
know there's yet I know there's some
people you just spoke at heterodox yeah
you just spoke at heterodox Jonathan
hates been on the show I think he's
doing wonderful work there's obviously
people like Brett and like Eric and and
Steven Pinker and plenty and Sam and
plenty of other that exists still as
sort of a sane left but I see that just
being whittled and whittled and whittled
away and that doesn't mean the fights
not worth taking it maybe it means it's
the most worthy fight but I just see it
as like an increasingly untenable
position to hold I think I think there
are actually many many many people out
there who are not who don't have public
platforms who are waiting who've been
waiting for this yeah who are watching
you most of these people would consider
themselves Democrats as I always did I
don't I don't want to identify as a
Democrat anymore given what they now
stand for but most I think that and this
you know as evidenced by my inbox so it
was anecdotal but it's a lot of Anna yes
and you know and also my Twitter feed
that there are a massive number of
people out there who are on the Left who
have values on the left and who find no
one out there who was making sense
except now except this girl emerge yeah
yeah and it it has taken it has taken
this - you have this fever-pitch that we
have arrived at for a number of people I
really think and like I said you know
Google Starbucks but it's not just those
big stories there are people writing to
me and to Brett from just average
workplaces saying I'm in fear for my job
because I
cannot speak anything that doesn't fit
the dogma we just hired an equity
advisor we've just hired an inclusion
advisor and it's and it's hateful it's
hateful rhetoric that we are being told
to adopt this is what's happening across
corporate America now of course most
Americans are not going to appreciate
that yeah it's like it existed at the
universities for a long time and finally
it started bubbling out of there and
those kids took those ideas and started
entering the workforce that's why it's
so worried you know people say you're
all you're focusing on college students
too much and it's like you do realize
they get out of college that's usually
right so tell me a little bit more about
sort of what you're doing now I know you
just spoke at heterodox and all right
let's start let's start with that
heterodox yeah yeah well the this was
heterodox Academy's first conference
they and fire are really at the
forefront institutionally of defending
viewpoint diversity on campuses fire
from more of a legal perspective and
heterodox at the faculty administrative
perspective and it was point was an
intense conference it's the only
conference I've ever been to where I
thought this should have been longer all
academics in the audience as well or do
they open that up there I think the
public eye I think there were probably
not academics there I know there were a
lot of journalists there and most
everyone I met were students or faculty
or admin or journalists so I don't know
I don't know what the what the entry
rules were but you know the panels were
as as Jonathan Hyde said at the end of
the day I Jonathan count only three
people who were on the panel's of I
guess twenty eight people who might be
conservative so he himself pointed out
you know we're striving for a few point
diversity but the fact is it's an uphill
battle you know we're not going to get
just just like we shouldn't expect a
50:50 sex ratio among soft software
engineers between men and women we're
not going to get a 50/50 ratio of
liberals and conservatives on college
campuses it's not necessarily the kind
of work the conservatives flock to in
the same numbers as liberals do so I
think you know we need to be careful
about imagining what what equity would
look like as in all of these argument
and at an idea level why would it be
that conservatives would be less
inclined to be doing academics I guess
it depends on what our definition of
conservative is one of a stereotype that
comes to mind that I may regret saying
is that liberal types take some odd
pride and not caring about making a good
living good money faculty positions tend
to tend to fit that right certainly
evergreen did so you know if you if what
if one of your primary goals is not only
to make a good living for yourself but
potentially to leap out of the living
your making and you know really hit it
big you're unlikely to do that in
academia so there's a there's a sort of
a risk aversion I think to the prospect
of making it big financially that
academics tend to have that maybe maybe
conservatives would be less likely to go
that way do you think it could also be
that conservatives were just
self-selecting out like they realized
that hostile atmosphere so they were
just like why would I do this absolutely
that is one of the explanations for sure
and you know certainly in some fields
you know an engineer the the less human
focused the field the more conservatives
there are we know this so in engineering
for instance in the more physical
sciences mostly people don't speak their
politics on college campuses if they are
on the right because they're not welcome
there but but those fields do have
higher representations of conservatives
than liberals but most of the social
sciences and Humanities were always
tended liberal but are even more so I
don't remember the numbers off the top
of my head but even more so now than
they ever have been and that's a problem
to have you know take you know to have a
field that is trying to understand the
nature of humans in any of the social
sciences psychology or anthropology or
sociology to be entirely limited to
people on the left side of the political
spectrum maybe you're missing something
in your explanation of what humans are
if you don't have anyone who's willing
to speak to a different political
position
so when I've talked to Jordan Peterson
who you referenced and my friend Peter
Bogosian and a couple other people who
are professors are you probably know
Pete
I think a lot of their argument is based
around that you know gender studies and
these sort of these sort of new fields
basically have a completely separate set
of standards that have virtually nothing
to do with any of the standards that you
as an evolutionary biologist had to add
to and have to prescribe to to do your
work is that really the crux of it sort
of at the institutional level high
schools I that is at least one of the
foci that I have seen as well that there
are many new fields many of which end in
the word studies like gender studies
that are right there they're made up
they are based in post-modernism and not
just not just post-modernism because
about its base originally there there's
some stuff of value there believe it or
not but the the new manifestations in
critical theory and such are are
basically free of any fact-checking
apparatus so they are they are anti
science they are from anti-enlightenment
and and they're quite willing to say
things like reason is a tool of the
patriarchy
yeah this is the new one this one
started popping up in the last six
months right and I mean you just have to
know you're dealing with people who are
not going to be playing in good faith
and willing to have an actually viable
argument at the point that they say that
so it's that there has been capture you
know pretty pretty solid capture and a
few of the more traditional fields not
entirely in fact I met several people at
heterodox who are sociologists who are
fighting this from within but sociology
is one of the captured fields in
anthropology geography and cultural
anthropology in particular so that the
fact that it is that there are fields
that students can go into and basically
never be exposed to the idea of you're
going to generate as many possible
explanations for the thing that you've
observed as possible we're going to
hypothesis generation first and then
we're going to try to figure out what
would have to be true if any if each of
those individual hypotheses were true
and then we're going to try to figure
out how to test between them that's the
scientific method and it's it's
inefficient it sometimes gets things
wrong but it is the only tool we have to
over time get to a better and better
understanding of the universe and
there's there's no there's a method yeah
over in gender studies yeah so how have
you seen that way of thinking leaked
into the harder sciences because this
seems to be the next frontier here yeah
there are there are some schools now
that when positions come open in in
science disciplines so muted most
schools this wasn't you at Evergreen but
at most schools sort of the hiring
apparatuses within within Department so
you know if someone in physics retires
and physics gets to decide the physics
faculty and department chair and such
get to decide what kind of physicists
they're going to hire next somehow
increasingly science educators are being
as being hired
rather than scientists themselves and
science educator is a code word for
people coming out of ed schools and
education schools have have this
pathogen mmm-hmm very very badly so
science educators being hired into
positions that should have been
scientists means that now you have a
weakening of scientific voice in
scientific method in science departments
hmm you have a I mean even I was it just
recently nature I think published you
know one of the two big science journals
published I don't worry if it was a
letter or an article arguing that one of
the primary things that science needs to
be focusing on is increasing diversity I
surface so you know two problems with
this what are your measures of diversity
it's the stuff that you can see on first
pass it's these immutable
characteristics and has nothing to do
with actually all the other kinds of
diversity that are interesting and that
you know and and that we can change
things like political belief and you
know some things that we can't change
but things like being on the autism
spectrum or you know even like you know
colorblindness or dyslexia or left
handedness all of which provide your
brain without us ever being conscious of
it some different way of approaching the
world and that kind of diversity in a
group of people ads ads actual intrigue
and nuance to conversations I'm a lefty
with a little dyslexia so lefty is like
you know like many other members of
these groups but I happen to happen to
know the lefty one because I've done
some research on it lefties are over
represented at you know in the National
Academy of Sciences and in mental
institutions I've got this really big
spread well now I can see that there's
really two options for your future
that's right alright let's talk about
consciousness a little bit I just had
Sam Harris on we've talked about it
quite extensively I think you have some
thoughts on consciousness the nature of
consciousness indeed yeah I mean it's
probably to do this right we would need
to agree on a definition and I'm not
sure that that's any definition that we
choose will immediately antagonize some
amount of your audience right this is
like the active way this is like
defining truth which seems to be tough
these days yes exactly so maybe maybe
rather than that there are humans the
only conscious beings on this planet I
don't think so but we have the most
conscious we are the most fully
conscious and we have better access to
our own consciousness obviously then we
have access to the consciousness of say
dolphins or elephants or other apes or
maybe wolves any of these long-lived
social organisms with long childhoods
and generational overlap who lived
sometimes with three generations
together at a time so this transmission
of cultural information organisms that
have theory of mind and can imagine can
put themselves in the other individuals
position and think what do they think is
going on right now even though I
understand that that's a different thing
than what I think is going on right now
right which we now know that certain
monkeys and apes exactly do that yes
theory of mind there's a beautiful book
called baboon metaphysics
by the husband and wife team Cheney and
save for that basically explores theory
of mind in baboons and you know it's
it's not the only one they're not the
only species but you know how do we as
humans find our consciousness best you
know there there are ways that we can
hack into what does some has been called
flow States or you know that's that's
the most common one but you know we can
do so through well through deep
conversation through meditation through
music some sometimes through producing
it but sometimes to experiencing
especially live music mm-hmm
dance for some people hallucinogens sex
sport you know intense physical or
physiological or emotional experience in
which we are just moving with others
usually and you know there are those of
us like myself you're very strong
introvert who will find so my deepest
flow space you know access to
consciousness alone you alone in the
Amazon when I could sit and watch
monkeys and write nothing for me that's
one of them but sport is also so when I
talked about this with Sam the way he
was defining it which i think is sort of
similar to what you're saying here it
strikes me as just like an extreme
ability to maintain present in the
moment that that really sort of when a
basketball player so if we use the sport
analogy like a basketball third when
they're in the zone you know and Jordan
scores 20 points in five minutes and he
just he go he said well everything I
threw up just went in like right that
they hit that level of consciousness or
for you to be outside enough out of
yourself to be able to write in that
perfect moment or whatever else but it
oh it always seems about being present
more than anything else do it there is a
kind of time stopping both times
stopping and disappearing on you at the
same time which i think is part of why
antigens hallucinogens can capture that
as well because they're the sense of
time just disappearing on you is is
remarkable so you you both don't care
about time and time passes usually in
ways that seem quicker than you're
expecting
- with with say sports or or write
meditation that you know that's not one
that I do but you know Sam has a lot to
say about that if yes yeah I remember
when I was doing mushrooms at least in
college age somewhat consistently maybe
every six months or something I would
always want the clocks to be covered yes
because I I hated the they're no good I
did I definitely did one trip like five
hours in a mirror forget that but I
always wanted the clocks to be covered
because the idea that time was passing
while I was in this yes state was was
very scary to me now that's scary or
just I just wanted nothing to do with it
I guess
right and that you know it's maybe it
doesn't matter what that distinction is
you know scary or just not interested
right but so it's it's very different
the the kinds of consciousness enhancing
activities that we can engage in
including hallucinogens are very
different if you're inside in a room
like this where you have no access to
what is going on climatologically or
weather-wise outside as opposed to if
you if you are out and you can watch as
the Sun sets and as the moon comes up
and you can think again oh right it's a
it's a it's a waxing moon it'll be full
in four days and or you know or or
you're at a coast and you can watch the
tides and think about the shifting time
so for me thinking about time that is
clearly being brought it's clearly being
revealed by the planet we're on as
opposed to coming at me through a clock
is more meaningful and I'm what I'm
willing to think about time in that way
but definitely not through clocks when
I'm when I'm writing hallucinogens sport
any of that right right
and yet we have all of these devices now
that are meant our time that are meant
to take our attention that are literally
designed this way do you sense we're on
like that there's actually a digital
assault on consciousness because maybe
that really does explain so many of the
other problems we're having in society
right now it's it's one of the key
pieces for sure and I think that phrase
is brilliant a digital assault on
consciousness this is something just on
Harris who
no but yeah I've had him on the show
yeah talks talks about a lot and you
know he's been he has been ringing the
alarm bell for years about the
algorithms that are being put into our
devices that are that are creating
addicts out of us know but more broadly
you know the digital assault
unconsciousness is there's not there is
it's increasingly hard to find a space
where you're just actually free and
clear and this is you know this is part
of what I do for myself and what I used
to do for my students was take them to
places not only that were remote and
where they could explore nature but
where there was no cell signal where
there was no internet so you know the
deepest part of the Amazon that I took
students to there's just there's no
email there's no internet there's no
Wi-Fi we are you know a plane ride over
the Andes and then a boat ride and then
a truck ride and then another five hours
down a tributary of the Amazon to a
place with no roads no air strips
nothing and boy does time feel different
and you know you're sleeping in little
cabins that are screened and so you wake
up when the insects and the birds and
the monkeys wake up and they start
talking at you they're not talking at
you they talk to themselves but you
getting a sense of the rhythms of the
planet that we're on can return people I
think to a real sense of self and also
to a sense of what they value what their
passions are and this is a big thing I
think is missing in many of the to
return to what we were talking about
earlier you know the the far-left
activists that the control left mostly I
think lack another passion and I've said
before I you know the prediction I would
make is that you have very few rock
climbers or skiers among the radical
left activists people who have something
that they can engage in that frees them
from time and devices from from a
response to time I need to be here then
or this my thing just pinged at me I
need to look at it are better able to
Center themselves to to find their own
consciousness and discover who who they
are and what they want to be in the
world what does that say about the self
do you think like it to me there's
something there about
if you really believe in the self and
your and the individual and your ability
to overcome things you don't need all
these external processes to helps define
the world because you're sort of
defining it yourself
I agree and I think I do think for me
self-sufficiency is one of my highest
values personally and I have a I have a
very hard time understanding anyone who
says oh if you leave me on my own I
wouldn't know what to do I just don't
get this I don't get why you would maybe
it's a leftie thing I'd be fine like
what why would why would you broadcast
to the world that you would be helpless
this doesn't make any sense to me but
and they're you know they're there
plenty of situations where I wouldn't
know what to do and I would know what to
do in situations that most people
wouldn't just because of where I've
traveled and where I've lived but the
idea that self-sufficiency requite the
idea that you want to be self-sufficient
requires a concept of self i think is is
important here yeah maybe just maybe
that yeah and if you give that up well
then boy you're given a lot you you give
up so much and the devices as as
heroness Tristan Harris has argued are
addicting us it's no accident you know
we should not view ourselves actually as
weak we when we get addicted to the
things we should wiener selves we should
as much as possible to provide ourselves
zones periods of time when we have no
access to those things and so we are
actually free and clear to let our minds
do what they will because when when we
when they have access to our brains they
are designed to detect us so using using
the discipline that you're an expert in
is it possible that we're in a unique
position right now because of Technology
that our brains are actually evolving
now evolving or I guess devolving
depending on which way you look at it at
an extraordinarily high pace or
something like that you know yeah the
rate of change across almost every
sector in the economy and in human
experience right now
higher than it's ever been could you say
that about any moment in history maybe
but the rate of change itself is
changing right as well right so that's
the important distinction right and what
is going on with technology is
completely untested and so this is this
is a place where you know why why am I
so certain that I'm still on the left
even though most of the people who say
they're on the left publicly I don't
have any interest in continuing to talk
to them because they don't seem to be
making any sense
I look at systems that are involved that
are that are in stable state because
they've evolved over millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions of years
and my instinct is don't mess with that
until you really really understand what
you're doing and so for instance I
unlike many scientists I'm not feeding
my children GMOs I mean I give them and
myself organic food and when we meet
which we do a lot of I want that meat to
have been fed the grass if it's at the
food of its ancestors mm-hmm what are
what exactly is the harm we now know a
little bit of this but twenty years ago
if you had asked me what's the harm in
feeding cows grains so I have no idea
but I know that messing with a system
that was working is more likely to
interfere with something in their animal
than not mm-hmm why you know why would
you mess if you could not and of course
there are economic reasons to mess but
the the don't mess with systems that are
working until you really have a solid
understanding of what the what the
effects are going to be the the use of
the precautionary principle pretty
widely yes is what puts me pretty far on
the left but systems that we've created
that are evolutionary but people don't
know that we need to regulate in order
to get them under control because
nuclear energy isn't going to regulate
itself and habitat loss throughout most
of the world is not going to regulate
itself so there are some problems that
we've created and that are bigger than
individuals can do anything about and
you know that's why I'm not a
libertarian yeah right and this is this
is where I think we have a I get it like
I don't know that if you just leave
everybody to do whatever the hell they
want all the time that everybody isn't
going to be doing also
awful things I think generally the
market does fix some of that but I get
what you're saying like these systems
are I suppose often precarious in nature
too to the point where anything could be
tilted one way or the other and then
then we've got bigger problems right so
how do we how do we fix some of this
stuff how do we how do we actually scale
this back I mean I get it you know most
of my audience will get okay well we
have to keep talking about it sure we
have to wait more people up sure but
what can you do
using the the knowledge you have and the
study you've done I have less I have
less insight right now at least to
answer in this amount of time for the
adult systems but I think I have a fair
amount of clarity on what we should do
should be doing with children and with
parenting
we're really really not doing which is
when you say the adult systems you mean
like economic systems and well and just
like and and more specifically how do
you get adults who are already who they
are to behave differently it's it's less
clear to me what what we can do and okay
so will will shell them for the purpose
yes and you know and the cysts yes also
also it's true that I have that I'm not
going to wade into for instance what we
should do a better economic system here
now with you I might do it later yeah
okay but with regard to for instance you
know most most people I think have never
thought about what childhood ends and if
you don't have children yourself and
you're an adult okay maybe I don't have
to maybe it doesn't matter like maybe it
just doesn't matter to you but if you're
a parent you need to think about why it
is that we have literally the longest
childhood relative to life span of any
organism on the planet this is a feature
this is a way for us to learn how to
become humans we are not and this is
this is a point that Brett has made very
often
we're not blank slates but we are the
blackest slates of any organisms on the
planet we we are more software than
hardware and so what we're doing for
these first I don't know
11 to 25 years of our lives right now in
just four days I think depending on
culture you know when do you start
calling yourself an adult
that's what we're doing is learning how
to be human and we're learning how to be
human by directing your supposed to be
learning how to be human
through instructor direct instruction by
our parents through observing our
parents through observing our siblings
through interacting with including
fighting with our siblings and having
them smack us down both sometimes
literally but definitely metaphorically
when we do stupid things and better yet
if our parents have lots of adult
friends around and they have lots of
kids and there's a whole mess of
humanity that we are learning from and
then we're also in that very long
developmental period supposed to be
learning from direct physical experience
of the world so the example I like to go
to here is you know the Roadrunner
cartoons when Wiley coyote scoots his
way off a cliff mm-hmm and he doesn't
fall until he realizes there's nothing
below him it's funny right like it's
really funny but of course it's funny
because we know that gravity doesn't
really work that way right increasingly
I suspect that a lot of kids and now
into a Gretchen and and some of the
younger Millennials kind of aren't sure
like they were protected so much by
their helicopter parents and they were
behind screens rather than having real
experience and to the extent that they
played sport it was totally regulated
and overseen by adults and they didn't
have any free time to go and get
themselves into trouble and maybe even
like burn something down and hurt
themselves or break an arm or whatever
it is and learn from it but they arrived
at the cusp of what should have been
adulthood totally unclear on what that's
supposed to mean
does this absolutely to you because as
I'm hearing you say that this is not the
bell going off in my head man I've been
on tour Peterson for the last six weeks
everything that you just said there is
basically what he is saying he is trying
to I sense that what he's trying to do
at the most personal level yeah he talks
about society as a whole but at the most
personal level he's trying to retool
young people it's not even retool he's
trying to give them the tools in the
first place that they clearly should
have gotten before
yeah so that's what's so fascinating to
me because it's like how did this happen
right how did how did this happen and
you know we can point to we can point to
pharmaceuticals being given to kids to
make boys less boy like and to some
degree to make girls less girl like you
know give great
let's give speed to boys so they'll sit
and face forward and learn what
so they'll calm down what do rough and
tumble play and I mean that's insane
yeah and at the same time let's give
anti-anxiety meds to girls and SSRIs and
and you know just just a model of
schooling is ridiculous you know we have
we have schools that have gotten rid of
recess because recess is dangerous and
when everyone who has ever been in
school even if like me you happen to
have been a good fit for the model of
schools that you were in which i think
is pretty rare actually knows that you
also need to have time to get out there
and play and move your body and
experience it and not have it being
overseen by some adult who's decided in
advance what is and is not safe for you
to experience so one of the things I
used to say to my students in advance
you know I did a lot of team building
and like actual team building and
planning with them in advance of these
long study abroad trips we would have
spent weeks together on campus in
advance of going on these trips but what
I wanted to do before we left was
established with them what's your
relationship with risk how do you how do
you view yourself your relationship with
risk and we would do this in around like
and I would answer the question too and
you know I would say to them actually I
happen to love risk I will I am the
leader on this trip but I will keep all
of you safe but then I'm gonna go do
things and you know I am going to walk
alone in the forest a lot and do things
because it happens to be one of the ways
that I find my consciousness that night
that I find my truest self and I don't
expect any of you to do that also but
you need to be comfortable with the fact
that your leader is going to be doing
that sort of thing and one of the other
things that we would talk about was you
know what's your relationship with
comfort you're gonna be uncomfortable
you could have to you know just because
you can say in advance you're okay with
the bugs and the mud and they're not
having a phone doesn't mean you actually
will be raised with
but maybe most important is we are going
to leave ourselves open to serendipity I
cannot tell you everything that we are
going to do or learn on this trip if I
could what would be the point of going
we're gonna go and some interesting
things are going to happen I've I've had
a couple of near-death experiences on
these trips I didn't want them made you
know I and you know I was there's a
learning experience for you there's a
learning experience and frankly on the
most recent one on a on a boat in the
Galapagos with eight students in which
the only thing that didn't survive was
the boat but it was it was really touch
and go I mean I really did almost die
those eight students and I are friends
for life right you know there's there's
some of them that I'm not an active
contact with but I I know where they are
and that you know that bonds you and no
I'm not gonna pitch a trick with and you
might die that's not what the goal is
but the idea that it could happen and
you should have the tools on board the
physical tools the psychological tools
the emotional tools intellectual tools
to figure out in a real time as your
boat is being flipped by a 15-foot wave
and now you're trapped under it what do
you do with that a uniquely evergreen
type of teaching was that saying that
you and Brett really that was a union
there me kind of teaching and this last
trip Brett was there with me as well
there was there was a way in which I
think what I said about childhood which
I you know my interest originally in
evolution was about the evolution of
parental care and territoriality and
social systems in sexual selection and
long before I ever had kids myself long
before I wanted kids but I thought you
know once Brett and I did have kids and
I'm watching these amazing creatures
begin to grow up okay let's think then
about what what is the best way to to do
this and we could put them in little
boxes and make absolutely sure that they
survive till the age of 18 and then we
open up the boxes and we let them out
and they are basically no chance of
being adults or even of knowing how to
be adults
or we could it
pose them to ever greater risk having
first made absolutely sure that they
know that they are loved and that we
have their backs and that we will do
anything to come in and get them and to
protect them if we can but that they are
going to start going out into the world
pretty early
you know biking it to and you know we
took them to the Amazon at 7:00 and 9:00
the first time and you know something
could have gone wrong and I don't know
I've known parents who lost kids and I
don't know how you survive that but you
need to be willing to take risks such
that when your kids do hit 18 or 20 or
whatever you know that they're actually
already on their way to being adults and
that is going to require backing off and
letting them do some of their learning
on their own and knowing that that's
going to result in some harm coming to
them and it's going to be physical harm
it's gonna be psychological harm it's
going to be intellectual harm but
frankly the the lack of any kind of harm
that a lot of kids are experiencing is
part of why they are now saying speech
is violence yeah right I mean that's
that's part of how we get there is some
of this an extension of the success of
the West in a way because if you take
the this set of kids who however old
they are let's say we go from although
now there's a lot of studies that are
showing that young the generation
younger than Millennials is actually
leaning more conservative but let's say
we take 16 to 30 roughly yeah so
Generation Y ish but you could that most
of their parents were baby boomers who
were the most successful at least
financially generation ever most of the
baby boomers parents all went to war and
you know lived through depression and
also itself but that because the baby
boomer is basically were the biggest
middle class and because there was such
upward mobility they had it so well they
kind of got their eye off the ball
started focusing on things that didn't
matter as much protecting kids from
things that a kid would have used to
have to have done and that is sort of
what led us here so it's almost like an
economic backing for what ended up
happening psychologically yeah I think I
think that's apt you know there's so
many things feeding into this and yes
the wealth of America post-world War two
and the fact that those are most of the
parents
of the generation that seems the most
confused they think definitely there's a
causal link there yeah and then you toss
in the internet and you toss on the
Internet
right which yeah we can't go back
obviously but but we need to understand
that it's an evolutionary system and
then it's going to run away from us and
that we are all prone to be addicted to
dopamine hits we're going to seek the
quick quick likes rather than you know
even even okay so take Internet out of
the picture for a moment if you I don't
know what you do for physical activity I
bike you play basketball so maybe with
basketball it's going to be different
for me I like video games too is that
better no that's probably the opposite
so I used to play a lot of Ultimate
Frisbee and you could oh like anytime
there's a pickup game like I would I'm
there I was playing five six times a
week for a while and then I ruptured my
Achilles tendon playing on an organ
beach with students a few years ago I'm
not doing that anymore
yeah but biking which I love and I find
meditative I have a very hard time
convincing myself to get on my bike even
though while I'm doing it I love it and
after I do it I feel better and I'm more
productive and I'm more creative and I
just didn't love with life but it's a
pain in the ass and it's a little bit
physically uncomfortable and you know
all of these things are true we we
prioritize the the pleasure of now over
even something that for me I know not
it's not even that I'm gonna feel better
after I did it I actually love the
activity itself mm-hmm but giving over
that sort of activation energy to do the
thing and I suspect that sport like
actually team sports is a little bit
different a little different like you're
ready to go you're ready to go I go
people are there I'm ready Oh like let's
yeah but going in the gym I would like
into that like I know that when I work
out I like doing it and I feel great
after but it's like oh I gotta get in my
car I got a driver
I got a parka bob feels like a chore
yeah yeah but you get you know it's good
and yet so we're always fighting our
nature sort of is we are no it's exactly
we're always fighting our nature and it
shouldn't surprise us that we're gonna
need to fight our nature with regard to
responding to the Internet and
responding to especially especially the
little computers we carry around in our
pockets and learning to restrict our
access to those training ourselves to
restrict our access to those I think
anyone with the ability to train
themselves to meditate or to do anything
on a regular basis should should be able
to train themselves that same way with
regard to devices yeah all right well
we've done about an hour here and I'm
gonna demand that you come back because
I know I know we can do way more that's
unfortunate just cuz my schedule is so
nuts at the moment we have to kind of
stop but can you give me one more thing
that you're just really excited about
right now that you've been thinking
about or working on or anything else
that's really just giving you a little
bit a little bit of juice at the moment
while you're in this interesting space
for yourself
no there are a number of things I guess
there's a there's a piece I wrote a
number of years ago that is supposed to
be out in a literary magazine just about
now-ish about having been mugged at
knifepoint in Quito one of these on one
of these study abroad trips which prompt
and I was with three students first
Quito
the capital of Ecuador okay so it was it
was the very it was before the first day
of one of my six-week study abroad trips
so twenty students just made Brett
wasn't there on this one and the
experience in which you know we'd been
we've been to get the three students and
I've been together all day we come to
the top of this stairs and suddenly two
guys with with knives run around the
corner and pinned me and my female
student up against a wall and do this
sort of knife dance in front of us and
then relieve I didn't have anything on
me because I know how to walk around
Latin American cities and one of my
students didn't but two of my students
had all of their stuff taken off them
including this really nice DSLR that
that Michelle my student had and they
run off and the next thing I realize
I am on one of these guys in the middle
of the street pulling on the backpack
he's stolen from another one of my
students another one of my students has
chased down the other guy Wow and I
thought how did that happen and why is
everything now so loud and so colorful
and I thought back immediately thought
wow the entire experience that I just
had was somehow in black and white and
was without sound and so I mean it's an
interesting long story that that I
basically explored in this essay by
going and doing doing a dive into the
literature on the nature of memory and
the nature of sensory memory in
particular and what it is that we can
and cannot perceive in the moment what
our brains take in why time seems to
slow down so just to go back to our
earlier position about time YTN time
seems to slow down in periods of
intensity it's not that it time slows
down but basically our frame rate
increases and not only our frame rate
increases but the amount that we
remember and you know move into
short-term memory and then in this case
into long-term memory increases so this
is this is one of the things that I've
been thinking about lately is sort of
how how memory and the senses and in
fact how all of us are a little bit of
synesthetes are experiencing our world
in ways that that we don't usually have
language for not that it was the purpose
of the story but how did this all end it
ended we got we got the stuff back Wow
um we got the stuff back and as soon as
the student jeremy and i gave chase
these guys and got the stuff back then
the police showed up
then the police searched stop lured up
from there and and the whole way i they
were watching it was it was remarkable
actually was towed there was no one on
this walk we'd seen no one
these two guys run up to us bug us run
off we give chase and then the entire
neighborhood comes alive suddenly there
were hundreds of people there like where
were you guys there's some sort of study
to be done on that well I'm sure they've
done Studies on that you know when
people sees a bad thing happening but
nobody calls the police all that kind of
stuff well listen it's been an absolute
pleasure I'm so glad that we finally got
to do this in person and we will do it
again
and you guys can follow Heather on the
Twitter she does tweet a decent amount
but not a unhealthy addicted amount I
would say it's at Heather hi
[Music]